americans held hostage behind enemy
lines day six
and welcome to hannity this friday night
americans held hostage behind enemy
lines this is day six and there is sadly
we can report no end in sight tonight a
month ago in july secretary of state
anthony blinken he was warned directly
five weeks ago by 23 top diplomats
inside of afghanistan that the fall of
kabul was in fact imminent the biden
administration ignored that dire warning
and here we are in this situation at
this hour where thousands of americans
tens of thousands of our afghan allies
are in extreme danger their lives are at
risk
many of these allies will be murdered if
they are left behind and the worst part
of all is
every bit of this was preventable but
the president of the united states he
has been completely checked out missing
in action he ignored every clear warning
that this was all going to occur in a
press conference earlier today joe biden
once again showed his true colors
repeatedly told outright lies to you the
american people man without character
career politician clearly no moral
compass
withering uh decrepit shell of a human
being who puts his own priorities
obviously above those fellow americans
abroad and until midday today joe's
plans were to go back on vacation in
delaware until he was pretty much shamed
into staying at the white house for the
weekend the reality for the country is
this we really don't have a president
seemingly aware and capable of leading
just watch joe biden lie again and again
today take a look
as we continue to work the logistics of
evacuation we're in constant contact
with the taliban working to ensure
civilians have safe passage to the
airport
safe passage to the airport
please tell me he's not serious because
his own state department sent a memo to
those trapped in afghanistan again today
reiterating quote the u.s government
cannot ensure your safe passage to the
airport oh and the gates might change
from time to time maybe joe didn't read
his own state department memo and look
at this in a briefing call with
lawmakers lloyd austin said americans
have been beaten by the taliban in kabul
outside of the airport some were beaten
with rubber fan belts joe biden clearly
lied his own state department and his
own defense department are highlighting
these lies the taliban is absolutely not
allowing safe passage watch with your
own eyes the president said he has no
intelligence that americans have been
unable to get there
the question obviously does that square
with reporting on the ground
i mean just totally not i don't think so
that
icon lived here because
journey not allowing anyone to go inside
the most intense part was getting into
the airport itself it was just
heartbreaking people pushing scrambling
crying screaming children
crying out
if you can't get in you're obviously
obviously then a hostage behind enemy
lines look at this headline quote
cnn abc nbc fox news correspondents fact
check biden on afghanistan evacuations
the reality and the rhetoric are miles
apart our very own jennifer griffin said
quote i'm having a hard time digesting
what we heard because i couldn't fact
check it in fast fast enough in real
time what's the point of controlling the
airport joe if you can't control the
perimeter the people controlling the
perimeter right now that would be the
taliban and if people can't get inside
how do we get them home it is so sad
that even joe's friends in the liberal
media cannot and will not be able to
shield him from this crisis and frankly
for good reason would you want your
family in the middle of this forced to
try and claw their way through several
taliban checkpoints in the midst of this
utter chaos and count and depend on the
good will of the taliban a terrorist
organization uh to allow you to go to
the airport when they're beating people
today's state department memo says we
can't secure your safe passage to the
airport and we can't guarantee what
entry points will still be open it is a
nightmare but the horrors don't end
there the lucky ones that have gotten
past the taliban beatings and the
checkpoints and actually made it to the
airport they are then forced to wait for
hours on end trapped between the walls
of the airport and the taliban fighters
that are surrounding the perimeter of
the airport behind them others are
forced to move from gate to gate to gate
until they can find one that is actually
open the gates open and close at a
moment's notice and in between each gate
is another taliban checkpoint according
to reports the taliban are using these
checkpoints they are searching for
anyone and everyone on their hit lists
and to make matters even worse tonight
for over eight hours today not a single
flight took off from that airport karzai
international airport not one the
primary reason for the holdup only a
handful of countries are now actually
accepting our flights including qatar
which they are now saying are at full
capacity they do not have the capacity
to take any more incoming flights and
meanwhile the ever so compassionate joe
biden is blocking
afghan refugees and their families from
flying to the united states uh i thought
that was a promise to them that if it
ever got this bad we would get them out
they don't have to stay here forever but
we promised them to get them out because
they will die and get this according to
joe biden all of our allies every one of
them they're applauding his heroic
leadership
okay another lie take a look
i have seen no question of our
credibility from our allies around the
world
i've spoken with our nato allies we've
spoken with nato allies
the secretary of state our national
security adviser has been in contact
with his counterparts throughout the
world and our allies as has
the general or excuse me i keep calling
them in general but my secretary of
defense
the fact of the matter is i have not
seen that matter of fact the exact
opposite i've gotten the exact opposite
thing is we're acting with dispatch
we're acting committing to what we said
we would do
here's a headline for you joe from the
telegraph quote british parliament holds
joe biden in contempt over afghanistan
here's another nato allies urge rethink
on alliance after biden's unilateral
afghanistan exit and another uk french
german leaders blast biden over
afghanistan we thought america was back
joe biden abandoned our allies our
friends our partners and even our own
fellow citizens in the middle of the
night frankly but don't worry according
to joe little chaos was bound to happen
that was all factored into this he said
and there's no reason for us to begin to
be in the region because al qaeda he
thinks
magically has disappeared perhaps nobody
told them that they were released from
prisons just days ago take a look
let's put this thing in perspective here
what interest do we have in afghanistan
at this point with al-qaeda gone
we went to afghanistan for the express
purpose of getting rid of al-qaeda in
afghanistan as well as as well as
getting osama bin laden and we did
and today joe's own pentagon said the
exact opposite that al qaeda is very
much alive and well in afghanistan
working alongside their taliban partners
and we don't even have an embassy
presence or intel assets left to counter
any threat and now the taliban may even
al-qaeda has access to massive
stockpiles billions of dollars of
sophisticated weaponry that we left
behind because there was no contingency
plan thousands of guns and armored
vehicles yep even blackhawk military
helicopters night vision goggles ammo
uniforms you name it they got it all
look at your screen these taliban
fighters are now mocking the united
states of america in their own
propaganda dressed up in gear taken that
we left that joe left them from u.s
stockpiles one notorious global
terrorist was even pictured with a u.s
m4 rifle flanked by other terrorists
wearing u.s military gear from head to
toe there's no plan to recover our gear
or weapons there was no plan to get rid
of them or destroy them there isn't even
a plan to rescue our fellow american
citizens yep that are held behind enemy
lines to get to the airport says biden
trust the taliban they've guaranteed
safe passage he's telling us uh take
your beatings risk your life we can't
ensure your safety
that's his plan that's it the taliban
feared president trump they realized
that their actions would have immediate
and dire consequences and as a result no
americans were killed for well over a
year in the last year of donald trump's
presidency now no one respects joe biden
not the taliban not our geopolitical
foes russia hostile regime china the
muellers in iran they're all watching
and guess what our allies don't even
trust us at this point and according to
a breaking new report from bloomberg
biden promised g7 leaders the u.s would
keep a security presence in afghanistan
to keep kabul safe and then utterly fail
to keep that promise well tonight i
always say let not your heart be
troubled my heart is troubled our fellow
americans are in deep trouble tonight
behind enemy lines our friends our
allies are in deep trouble behind enemy
lines you know leave no man or woman
behind well great britain and france to
their credit they sent in troops to
kabul to escort citizens from kabul
successfully to the airport why haven't
we we have the best military fighting
force on the face of the earth yeah
americans now can't get to the airport
held hostage and they're behind enemy
lines day six joining us now with more
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else